So we invented a third type of cache,
which is called virtually indexed and
physically tagged cache,
which is trying to combine the
advantages of the two types of cache.
It works like this.
We start with the virtual address,
we break it down into the cache offset,
index and tag, but we don't use the tag.
We do use the index bits
from the virtual address
to find the set that
we want in the cache.
We read the valid bits and
the tags here.
But meanwhile, we use the page
number from the virtual address to
access the TLB and get the frame number.
So now that we got the physical address,
we perform the tag check using the
physical address not the virtual one.
This is why this is
called a virtual index.
The index bits come from
the virtual address.
The tag bits come from
the physical address, cache.
And from here, it proceeds normally,
we know whether we have a hit and so on.
So how does this help?
Note that the cache array and the TLB
access are proceeding in parallel.
So if the TLB is fast enough and
usually it is because it's small,
the hit time will be equal
to the cache hit time.
It's actually the maximum of the two,
which is usually the cache hit time.
So this is just like the virtual or
virtual index virtually tagged cache and
we like that.
We get the speed advantage of
the virtual caches with this type of
cache too.
Do we need to flush on a context switch?
Well, it turns out no.
Because if we switch the process, so
that virtual addresses correspond
to different physical addresses.
What we find in the cache will be
checked against the actual physical
address.
So the virtual address in another
process will map maybe to the same set.
But once it maps there,
the actual tag is not going to match,
because these two have different tags.
So this is like the physical cache and
is nice, but what about aliasing?
Recall that aliasing happens,
because multiple virtual addresses in
the same address space might map
to the same physical address.
But because we do virtual
access to the cache,
these addresses might end up in
different places in the cache.
Thus, right to one will
not be seen by the other.
It turns out that there are no aliasing
problems in the virtually index physical
tagged cache,
as long as the cache is small enough and
it has to do with where
are the index bits coming from.
So this is very, very nice, because it
basically gives us the correctness.
The no flush on context switch of
the physical caches with the hit time
of the virtual caches,
but let's figure out what do we need
to do in order to not have aliasing.